ich hab sogar zwischen hupen
hallöchen freuen und herzlich willkommen
endlich mal wieder hier zu einer app die
ich mit euch spielen wollte und zwar ist
sie metric da ich spiele das hier so wie
immer auf meinem ipad und ihr seht schon
dadurch dass ihr ist ja eh grad auch
eingeblendet sehen und ich das gar nicht
zeigen muss ihr seht schon da ist unten
links und kleiner finger der zeigt auf
normal und da können wir einfach mal
drauf klicken auf lern und jetzt spielen
wir zusammen dieses erste level und
versuchen uns da so ein bisschen durch
zu finden ich bin doch dieses spiel
gekommen weil viele meinten das sei so
ähnlich die flat liebert und das sollte
ich mal wieder spielen und ein bisschen
ausrasten und irgendwie so aber
irgendwie glaubt okay ich nehme mein
free herz auch das ist nicht wahr
jetzt muss ich mir wieder deine scheiss
werbung von diesem scheiss auf frisch
viel an krücken mit einem tablet oder
smartphone
es ist auf jeden fall super aber nee ich
werde nicht spielen nation youth and you
know it's ok super dann nehmen wir das
dabei direkt mit hier für unser immer
noch lernen level sind wir glaube ich
eher das ist so kompliziert die scheiße
auf dem ipad zu spielen ich hab was wo
bin ich denn gegen gegangen ich muss das
irgendwie so mit meinem arm so ein
bisschen anders spielen weil ich mit dem
daumen da nicht ganz herum komme das ist
es viel zu kompliziert das leben ist
wissen diese beiden dort agieren im
gleichklang und wenn ich den einen
rückzieher
kommt der andere zu anderen seite habe
ich kann ihn nicht weiter auseinander
ziehen als so und muss jetzt hier um
diese scheiße irgendwie rum und das ist
immer noch das lernen level aber wir
werden heute ich verspreche euch auf
jeden fall noch auf level hart kämpfen
wollt ihr eigentlich dass ich in zukunft
mal wieder mehr so iphone und ipad
spiele spiele wurden ein paar
interessante spiele zuge seiner kann ich
davon der mal ein paar zacken also
natürlich echte an läuft bei uns all das
ist überhaupt nicht schwer war nur hier
gesetzt haben und jetzt kommen wieder
eine kugel oder glas oder ich hab sogar
zwischen huber sieht als wenn man noch
drogen wäre das wirklich scheiße hier
kann ich eh nicht irgendwie zurück oder
so ich möchte nicht gern machen ich will
wir gehen jetzt mal beikommen wir jetzt
mal p7 herzen habe ich noch ich kann
doch kann ich nicht einfach mal so ein
leben in die benutzen also eher alter
das ist schon schnell auf so ne allen
dieses spiel ist nicht so gerade das
flüssige komplett zuvor
also irgendwie durch die ganze scheiße
ruckelt das auch total man beim
fernsehen habe ich noch keinen sinn was
für eine scheiße bekommen sie es mit
viel zu einfach glaube ich nehme einfach
mal orchester schnell alter für
christian herz kollert aber bisher
schlag ich nicht nehmen
ich mach das jetzt noch mal auf normal
warum sie diese weiter auseinander komme
runter bruder hat mich wenigstens kommt
von 5 schaffen auf hart ich darf dir auf
jeden fall nicht so nah
auseinandernehmen
ich nehme jetzt ganz kleine namen und es
kann auch nicht sein wir müssen doch bei
hard mindestens fünf schaffen kommen
jetzt hier um jede kugel ein sehr sehr
interessantes 12.000 leute spielt die
scheiße das ist doch nicht kann das denn
nicht irgendwie mal mir entgegenkommen
dieses spiel ich gehe hier rein wie so
ein motivierter fleischklops und die
kommen wir haben die sonne [ __ ]
verhaftete scheiße war
das ist doch nicht wahr
ich muss es doch wohl hinkriegen das ist
doch ich glaube ich mache jetzt eine
andere taktik ich mache das einfach so
ich rede nicht aufregen luca nicht
aufregen kann ich denn nicht gegend wie
das ganze mal mit einer anderen taktik
angehen dass ich einfach es hat geklappt
aber ich kann noch zu drehen schaut
achtet ob man da ist einfach am tag
reicht und ich trifft genau den kreis
mit meinem dingen darauf taktik anwenden
so rumdrehen rumdrehen rumdrehen ich
verziehe mich hier schon von space camp
sich gerade ich muss so sitzt natürlich
in der face campbell man das kann doch
nicht gut ist gut dass mal die face kein
bisschen verstellt ich glaube dann
solltet ihr mich besser sehen
guck mal direkt face kämpfer ich war
gerade sagen guck mal feldkamp verstellt
und es klappt dabei das klappt nicht
guck mal das ist man jetzt taktik mit
oben drehen du scheiß spiel sollst dich
um die kacke rumdrehen du sollst nicht
dagegen fliegt guckst du drehst dich in
dem uhrzeigersinn verdammte scheiße
bimmelt da die ganze zeit gegen mit
senden
dieses spiel ist auch so ein richtiger
ein richtiger dem wurde immer damals in
der grundschule bestimmt das pausenbrot
geklaut deswegen haben die entwickler
sich jetzt gedacht kommen die ganzen
nushi spielen unser spiel spielen
apropos 15 es ist gerade als vor 5 das
kann doch nicht sein ich mein ziel ist
einmal bei hard 5 stück zu schaffen
danach höre ich direkt auf und verschone
euch mit dieser ich weiß gar nicht was
meine nachbarn auch gerade von mir
denken denken war der luca der spd zudem
kräftig in die wege die spielt bestimmt
kann die magic gehört selber oder so ist
will dass man dann eine nachbarin so ein
bisschen man das kann noch nicht sagen
er spielt mit der nase und mehr als nur
gestoppt
bal ist genau da wo ich hin muss wie
soll ich da dran vorbei
das ist eine app das spiel einfach nur
100 leute aber trotzdem besser aus dass
dieser eine mysteriöse aber ich kann mir
das nicht vorstellen dass da überhaupt
jacke an meinem kopfschutz gehabt
gekommen jetzt bitte was kompletter
versuche ich habe der ganze spuk ihr weg
gemacht jetzt ist mein ganzes ipad voll
werbung in dem spiel symmetrics für das
spiel symmetrics gut rest nur die info
ich weiß nicht was kann ich denn man
kann auch ja war wahrscheinlich brauche
ich dreißig mal 27
quatsch wir konzentrieren uns natürlich
nur auf das level hart wo ich seit zehn
gefühlten scheiß jahren
das war angedeutet wenn man beim fußball
jemanden berührt dann ist es auch nicht
direkt ein foul und kriegten rote karte
und jetzt diese bälle alter wer braucht
die denn
guck mal was wollen die denn die haben
doch keine freundin diese bild ich will
ich will ja nie vulgär werden in meinen
videos aber wenn da so eine kacke kommt
dann kann man halt nicht anders ist ja
gut ich bin natürlich auch gerade wie
soll ich denn ich bin the trick dort
meine spieler sind alle an verzweifeln
ok andere sagt ich sage jetzt bei scor
versuche ich zu knacken als ich versuche
viel hinzukriegen dass man nicht es
klingt wie soll ich denn so schnell
reagieren ich komme nicht mehr so
schnell an die teile wenn nicht auf
stadt gerückt habe so jetzt mal ein
vernünftiger staat hierdurch hier
durchkommen zack zack
die aqua computer okay wir schaffen
jetzt fünf kommen das war so einander 5
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
wieso würde ich denn so helga k
ich habe das ganze level geschafft man
die junge aber ich würde sagen meine
lieben freunde mein highscore ist 11 das
ist extrem gut also ich finds gut für
hart wenn es euch gefallen hat meine
softbox ein bisschen dunkler geworden
aber wenns euch trotzdem gefallen hat
würde ich mich definitiv über eine
bewertung freuen wenn ihr mehr direkt
auf dem ipad wollt dann zeigt es mir mit
einer bewertung oder schreibe es in die
kommentare und dann sehen wir uns
bei den fans wieder glaube ich wenn
morgen kommen sollten ich habe meine
wohnung geschmissen